in the lobby a financial peace plasma
Michelle is with us hi Michelle how are
you what's up kiddo how are you doing
I'm better than I deserve
oh yeah Dave I am so blessed and honored
to be here thank you so much for all
that you do for the world and ministry
and just showing people how to be
debt-free thank you but they can also
have to say praise Jesus for this
opportunity god I love you and thank you
so much for giving me this this
wonderful amazing journey god I thank
you and I love you I love it I love it
how much have you paid off kiddo babe
I'm paid off one hundred and ninety one
thousand three hundred forty three
dollars and fifty cents
got to the head Bob with the fifty cents
a good get the hair that's it love it so
how long did this take you that's a
bunch
yes David took me 52 months - yes four
years was that your house - that was my
house and everything you rock and you
know what there's nothing like walking
on bear grass paid for grass and your
bare feet that's right it's yours
you got it figured out you even do that
Indianapolis cases and so what was your
average income through this time so I
started at a little less than a hundred
and finished that right at a hundred way
to go what do you do for a living I do
consulting work for an accounting firm
good for you yes no fetchin that's
exciting good when you do it so what
happened 52 months ago that made you
decide you were going to get out of that
you know what Dave I learned God's
principles for managing money and I read
proverbs 22:7 where it says just as the
rich rule the poor so the borrower is
servant to the lender Dave I decided it
was no longer time for me to be
anybody's servant I hear you so that was
that was my story my starting point and
you know my childhood I grew up in a
single-parent home mommy I love you
Queen Thomas you have been awesome in my
life and awesome inspiration we grew up
in a housing project and my mom always
instilled in her children hope and she
taught us hard work and I remember
walking into my mother's room one night
and she was on her knees praying and
crying because she didn't know how she
was going to feed her children and God
provided my mother kept bathing us in
prayer and she led us and I know you
have a lot of listeners today but Dave
if there is a single mother listening to
this show I want to inspire them to give
them hope to know that you can make it
out of your situation no matter what it
is and for those children that are
growing up in that home God has a plan
for your life you have to give up you
have to not give up you have to keep
pushing you have to keep striving and I
am so grateful and honored that the Lord
saw fit to bring me here today go Jesus
I love it hey that's pretty cool I mean
that's a neat story all the way from the
the projects with a single mom beside
the bed praying all the way to make a
100 grand an accounting consultant you
do rock yeah it is very cool I'm proud
of you I'm proud of you God God has
blessed that's amazing yes so I that you
just look up one day and you say this
isn't gonna work I'm going to get out of
debt because the scripture says
otherwise because the scripture says
otherwise and in Deuteronomy 28 it talks
about the blessings that will bestow be
given to us if we're obedient to God and
then it also talks about the courser
system Dave I don't like curses okay
I don't like curses no it was important
to me to act in obedience to you know
the Lord and so I decided you know this
is my opportunity I want God's plan to
fall and rest and his purpose to be
solely rested in my life so how'd you do
it how'd you get out of that so let me
tell you okay I have a story for you so
first thing I did was I prayed you know
if I had you know I had to pray and ask
the Lord God what direction do you want
me to go in but then I had to get on a
ridden budget day you know how it is
with the written budget and so I got on
the rich and the written budget but then
also I started cutting back Dave I cut
the cable my friends thought I was
absolutely crazy but I cut the cable and
and and I would tell my friends if you
come to my house in the wintertime
you're gonna be cold and if you come to
my house in the summertime you're gonna
be hot mm-hmm and so you know I made you
know sacrifices like that I didn't go on
many vacations during that time and stop
shopping and you know doing a lot of
things like that and so another thing
that I did is I started helping people
other people get on a debt and so I was
able to make some money on the side
doing that so Dave I got a hustle there
you go hustles all about right so what's
this house worth so the house is
probably worth about 260 270 now and
it's yours it's my voice oh very cool
yes man and so you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is what I think
the key to getting out of debt is number
one obedience you have to be obedient to
what the Word of God says but I also
think you have to make sacrifices and
you have to be willing to live like no
one else so you can live like no one
else offered up yeah you know this wise
guy once you know I heard him say it so
I just push it along to other people you
say that lot of different ways wise guy
or wise guy all right so this is
incredible that is a beautiful picture
of that house we just showed it on the
shoulder on the video channel it's a
nice house thank you thank you nice
houses
8:4 paid two hundred and sixty thousand
dollar house yes and how much of the 191
was mortgage I love it oh it was the
whole thing's mourning the whole thing
get rid of the mortgage yes pound and
pound and pound about now stomped it out
what was the weirdest thing you did to
get out of that you cut the cable and
you cut the power don't the heat and the
air that back I got that part you turn
the thermostat back some better way of
saying it now what else did you do that
was weird so I think one of the other
things that I did that was weird was I
used a lot of coupons mm-hmm
so um like a lot like a lot
a lot and shopping on sales and buying
deals and you know just things like that
and and Dave I hate to use this example
but I you know I picked up money when I
saw a dime or penny on the streets I
would pick it up Dave because every
little bit counts hey you win death by a
thousand cuts that's how you raise right
and so it's amazing how when you're
smart things that start happening Jen
you add up those coupons I started
adding up to some serious money yes
especially over 52 months you've been
doing this 52 months Dave yeah 52 is a
long time yes it not do people did
people make fun of you oh yes look let
me tell you I cooked breakfast for a
group of friends one morning okay I had
one young lady come to my house and she
said you people kill me buying these big
houses and can't afford to heat them and
she didn't know what plan I was on and
so I just laughed in my head and when
she found out that I was deaf free she
was like oh it makes sense now yeah yeah
so yes people didn't laugh I'll be
running your mouth that's what I'll do
you exactly exactly exactly yes awesome
and so Dave you know I I am Here I am
single but I really have to say thank
you for you know to all the people who
supported me from my mother Queen Thomas
my sister Anita Poli and my
brother-in-law Frank Polian my friends
who drove me here to be on your show
because they were so excited for me
why Nita and Courtney Gordon guys I love
you thank you so much and to my pastor M
Troy Smith that's all of our Bible
Church who has awesome leadership and
who has allowed me to operate in the
gifts that God has blessed me with
Pastor I love you and so I am just so
fortunate and honored that God has
surrounded me with people who have
supported me throughout my journey and
I'm just ready to give back you're
awesome
immigration like she's accepting the
Academy Award right that's part of it
morphic my dog I want my dog Travis now
working all the little people and
it's awesome I love it
you're great you're great all right here
we go Michelle from Indianapolis 191
thousand dollars paid off
52 months making a hundred thousand a
year counted down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
I love it
boom she does get the award of the best
of the week no question way to go
Michelle very well done
people are fired up everywhere after
listening to that I love it I love it I
love it this is the Dave Ramsey show
you